two u.s navy ships have sailed through
the taiwan strait in a passage the white
house described as being consistent with
international law the sailing comes just
weeks after the visit of u.s house
speaker nancy pelosi to taiwan
china objected to the visit and held its
largest ever military drills around the
island to which taiwan responded with
its own set of exercises
all this has brought into sharp relief
the question of how taiwan defends
itself against any possible chinese
invasion
dw's zachary lee and cherry chan report
robin she loves military hardware he's a
tour guide by day but for the past two
decades he spent his spare time taking
pictures of military exercises
when taiwan responded to chinese drills
earlier this month with miso tests of
its own
she was right there filming
[Music]
i got here more than two hours before
the announced time of the tests i was
worried that many people would come i
wanted to get the best spot
as a former navi radar operator she also
listens to radio message and tracks
movement by both the taiwanese and
chinese armed forces around the island
he says taiwan has not done enough to
improve its military strength
we have never wanted to attack anyone
we are only developing weapons for
self-defense
we should do more of that
so he is happy to see that here in
pindon county a weapons manufacturer is
carrying out missile and rocket tests
taiwan faces unprecedented provocation
from china and now it is much more eager
to develop its own missiles
at this military base behind me a
taiwanese weapon developer is conducting
a series of live fire missile tests this
next month
they are held here regularly but with
escalating threats from china
they carry more significance than ever
military experts say taiwan needs to
establish its own defense strategy but
now one based merely on how many weapons
it has
woman
we must get better at asymmetric warfare
if we try to compete on the number of
weapons we will be dragged into an arms
race
that would be really bad for us
he says taiwan has tried to move away
from buying weapons from just one
country the u.s
but that has proved almost impossible
many countries have cited a variety of
reasons for refusing to sell arms to
taiwan
we have always wanted to acquire
submarines from germany
for robinshi the message is clear
taiwan needs to be more confident in
developing its own defensive
capabilities only land can stay up to
the threat from abroad
and norway is that threat felt more
acutely perhaps than taiwan's jinmen
island which lies less than five
kilometers from china's coastline and
dw's chief international editor richard
walker joins me now from june man
richard from where you are give us a
sense of the scale of the threat that
taiwan's facing
yeah well biresh there really is a sense
at the moment that the the threat from
china is as big as it's ever been um and
there's a sense of a potential kind of
moment of truth approaching down the
line but just to give you a little bit
of scene setting first of all of where i
am here i'm on an island actually called
little jin men which is off jin man this
cluster of islands uh controlled by
taiwan very close to the chinese
mainland and if you just look behind me
across the bay here through the haze you
can see the chinese city of shaman
across the water
less than five kilometers just like you
said and it really it it feels so close
and these islands jin men they're no
stranger to the china threat so at the
very end
of the civil war in 1949 the pla
were
landing on these shores trying to take
these islands at the very end of the
civil war and you still see uh these
spikes uh these defensive spikes which
are against uh uh landings taking place
here uh which are dotted all around
these islands everywhere so these
islands really exude this sort of
history of the conflict between china
and taiwan
but just very recently during the
chinese exercises that took place to
complain about the visit of u.s speaker
nancy pelosi
one of these islands just the next one
along was buzzed by a chinese drone and
the chinese released footage from that
drone which showed taiwanese soldiers on
the ground throwing rocks at this drone
to try to shoot away and this really
brought home some of the problems that
taiwan faces at the moment the sheer
proximity of china but also the fact
that all they had to to show away these
drones were rocks so the chinese
government has been rushing now uh to
say that they're going to secure for
next year all sorts of anti-drone
technologies but but really a kind of a
little palpable and rather embarrassing
reminder there of the threat
and obviously leads to the larger
question of what is taiwan's strategy to
defend itself from a much bigger
neighbor
yeah well i mean this is really an
ongoing debate that's been heightened
this year not just because of the pelosi
visit but also because of the ukraine
war uh that's been really something of a
wake up call not just for taiwanese
politicians but taiwanese military but
also ordinary time and his people
thinking gosh if it can happen there it
can happen here and this is added to the
debate and we heard referred to just in
the report there about asymmetric
warfare the fact that taiwan will never
be able to match up with the chinese in
terms of numbers or in terms of military
budget so that it needs to be smart
about using its limited military budget
to buy the kind of weapons that it might
be able to use to fight a bit like the
ukrainians in in an invasion scenario
but even that is controversial with some
people saying well you can't just
go for the sort of weapons that allow
you to fight back once someone's invaded
you also want to deter that invasion so
really what you need is a sort of
balance between big ticket military
items and the smaller scale ones but
this does bring us also to a certain
amount of tension between taiwan and the
united states with the sense that i've
been getting from some people talking to
i've been talking to privately here in
taiwan that they get the sense that the
americans still been dragging their feet
in providing some of the weapons that
they really need so all is not
necessarily particularly well also in
the relationship between the us and
taiwan
in dealing with this threat from china
you earlier spoke of a moment of truth
approaching richard has that
moment of truth arrived there because of
nancy spear nancy pelosi's recent visit
well i i don't think so i mean there are
all sorts of different takes on nancy
pelosi's visit and what the chinese
exercises that took place after it mean
um some people i've been talking to here
say that they do feel that the chinese
did show a degree of restraint in those
exercises but what they also did was
establish what's been talked about as a
new normal the chinese
fighter jets for instance now go further
than they did across what's called the
median line at the line sort of in
between taiwan and china
on the in the taiwan strait but the kind
of moment of truth that i'm really
talking about here is the fact that
china says that it wants to reunify as
they put it with taiwan and a great
majority of the people of taiwan say
that they simply don't want that how do
you resolve that then without going to
war
richard walker
lovely talking to you thank you so much
for joining us from genman island
and tensions over taiwan are having an
impact on other countries in the region
as well japan for instance
its westernmost island yonaguni lies
just 108 kilometers east of taiwan it is
in fact closer to taipei than it is to
tokyo and that has its 1500 residents
worried it could become a new front line
if hostilities break out in the future
fisherman ishinari toshitsugu makes
everything ship shape for his next big
catch he needs one urgently because he
hasn't been able to fish as usual
after the recent chinese military drills
around taiwan the 32 year old was banned
from heading out to sea for five days it
was deemed too dangerous because of the
proximity to the contested island nearby
the rockets fell into the sea just 80
kilometers from here we could hear it
happen and how did the government in
tokyo react with a silly piece of paper
they sent us a fax to inform us about it
what am i to make of that
the island of yonaguni is some two
thousand kilometers from tokyo but it
feels like half a world away
fishing and pony breeding are the
economic lifeblood of the island which
rarely receives visitors
our cameras are a cause of interest
straight
but i recently started worrying about
the future
the future of the island or rather the
protection of it has traditionally been
entrusted to the so-called shisa
mythical guardians made of stone that
keep evil spirits away
but the mayor isn't happy to rely on
them for protection against china
he wants to be able to evacuate the
island in the event of an attack which
is a challenge considering the small
harbor and short runway
it's all about saving lives
it's crucial to avoid a scenario like in
ukraine
where civilians and soldiers are bundled
up together
[Music]
the island is home to a radar station
and 160 defense troops have taken up
residence to monitor the airspace and
the sea
but nobody on the island really believes
that they can prevent a potential attack
by china
in the japanese parliament in tokyo
he understands the concerns of
yonaguni's residence
but says it's important to look at the
big picture
the whole area is a battlefield he says
not just taiwan
all of this area
it's not just about yonaguni but also
about the hundreds of thousands of
residents of the other islands in the
vicinity about the evacuation of the
taiwanese japanese americans and
europeans who live there
we also have the difficult task of
improving our defense capabilities in
the region
in the meantime the fishermen of
yonaguni are still waiting for their
next big catch
hoping that peace prevails on the island
and beyond